- What's up everybody?
Hope you enjoyed today's mashup.
Appreciate anytime fan love comes.
It's just remarkable and it's always fun
to give exposure to people
that are putting out their work.
I also love the topic of
controlling what you can control.
The enormous delta I
see in the marketplace
is most people just dwell about things
they can't control instead
of focusing on what they can
and I think this does an extremely
good job explaining that.
Do you know yourself?
Or do you aspire to be something
you might actually not be?
You have the dream but
you have to execute it.
And it's just gonna take you time.
'Cause either at 15
you're gonna make it up
and try to front, which
is your vulnerability,
or you'll just put in the work,
put in the work, put in
the work, and that's it.
It's just a process, man.
Life is the fun.
You know?
Just put out the work, put out the work.
We are just completely
in this incredible place
of unlimited options.
I just struggle with people's inability
to have perspective on where they sit
in opportunity in a 7.7
billion person world.
The quickest and easiest way
to get to do what you want
while paying your bills,
is to start sacrificing
leisure and other things
and start focusing on monetizing the thing
that you wanna do in the future.
I used to drag through school.
By the time it got to
3:30, I was like dead,
'cause I hated it.
So you can't put in the
hours unless you love it.
That's why I believe loving it
leads to the most success
because I think somebody else
loves what you don't love,
that you're doing for money,
thus they'll be more successful
'cause they're gonna do it for 19 hours.
Now, there's talent.
- [Woman] Yes.
- You may not love singing
and you open up your mouth
and you sound like Whitney Houston.
That's real.
You may not love...
There's athletes, absolutely, I know them,
who are not passionate about their sport
but they were born six foot
10 and very coordinated.
So it happens.
It happens.
But I think that's the rarity.
Your rank amongst the 7.7
billion people in the world
when it comes to
opportunity is ridiculous.
(audience cheering)
To have a special life, you
have to do special things.
And that usually means putting
in the work and loving it.
You take your advantages.
Some advantages are experience.
Some advantages are youth.
You have to deploy patience.
It's not gonna happen overnight.
- Right, that's what I learned from you.
- I put out content for
eight and a half years
before anybody gave a (censored).
- You have to dream.
- Please factor in what the
world's going to be like
in 2019 to 2025 versus looking
at what the world was like 2009 to 2015.
Way too many decisions
by way too many people
are being made by factoring in the past
without anticipating the future.
Forget about Benzs and
shoes and homes and planes.
The ROI of life is not money.
It's being happy.
And when I look at the people
that I see that are happy,
regardless of their income levels
or success or fame or notoriety or money,
so much of that is completely predicated
on the fact that either their parenting
or circumstance helped them
have actual perspective
to what the hell is going on here.
Do you know what I wish
for all of you 25 year-olds in here?
That you knew how young you feel at 40.
News alert, you're gonna
kinda feel exactly the same.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with chasing money.
I just think that it's
usually the quickest way
not to get it.
I am remarkably stunned by
the lack of accountability
in our society.
Everything wrong at Vayner Media,
anything that ever happens,
any piece of content,
anything that ever happens in my life,
100% is my fault.
(audience cheering)
And let me tell you what
happens with accountability.
You get real happy.
When you feel that there's no other source
controlling your (censored),
all of a sudden it gets happier.
Your ego and your insecurity
doesn't wanna take the L.
You don't wanna admit
that you (censored) up.
Because for some reason,
so many of you are living your lives
based on other people's opinions
and that is crippling you.
The way to really eliminate fear
is by not giving a (censored)
about anybody's opinion.
My losses are mine.
I'll deal with them myself.
I don't need your two cents.
You're losing plenty on your own.
Patience and inner voice
makes you unbeatable.
This phone is more
powerful technology-wise
than the computers that Ronald Reagan
had to run the free world.
This thing, while you lay
in bed from seven p.m.
to two in the morning, is your gateway
to get out of the thing
that you complain about,
yet, we'd rather watch entire seasons
of "Friends" again on Netflix.
The one thing that connects everyone here,
regardless of you're
winning, you're losing,
company, employee, entrepreneur.
The one thing from coast to coast
that connects every person here
is the one asset that we should
all be chasing is attention.
Before you achieve anything,
whatever the hell you came here for,
when you go and output to
try to create your business,
run for mayor, raise
money for a non-profit,
no matter what you do,
no matter what you try to accomplish
when you leave this conference,
the one thing that you should be chasing
is people's attention.
Before you can accomplish
selling a sneaker
or a cookie or a T-shirt or insurance
or whatever you do,
you need somebody's
attention to tell them.
Then your message has
to be on point enough
to commit them into doing what you'd like.
Attention, my friends, is the asset.
Nothing else is important
to me besides attention.
The reason I've always
adapted to new content
and new platforms, the internet itself,
email, YouTube, Google AdWords,
Facebook, Twitter, podcasting, all of it,
the reason I've always done well with that
is my religion above anything else
is where is the attention today
and potentially tomorrow,
not what worked yesterday.
(calm instrumental)
It's crazy how I feel my whole life.
Never had peer pressure,
never did anything, anything,
ever, ever, that I didn't want to do,
because I just didn't value
somebody else's opinion over mine.
And that comes from good parenting,
circumstance, DNA, a million things.
I don't know how to teach that.
What I'm just trying to do
is I'm trying to beca...
In a weird way, I like being popular
because I become your courage.
I think the most flattering thing
that's happening to me in my life
is I'm becoming people's courage
because when they take risks
and they take ridicule, they point to me.
And then I tell their parents
to go (censored) themselves.
It makes the most sense in the world
to go high risk in your youth
'cause you can live at
your parents' house.
You two and 19 people watching
can live in a studio 21 deep.
I know it.
I lived it. I saw it.
I watched it.
This is exactly when you guys
are supposed to take
two core leaps of faith.
Either go do it for yourself
or get close to something that
you believe in completely.
If you let somebody else's opinion,
whether your spouse, your boss,
your mom, your aunt, your best friend.
If you genuinely, genuinely
are living your only life,
which oh by the way, by
modern scientific terminology
is 400 trillion to one.
If you even could comprehend
how ridiculous it is
that we are even alive.
Do you understand how ludicrous it is
that you have a life?
There's nothing mathematically in life
that can happen that is more ridiculous
than the fact that you got one.
You're more likely to get
struck by lightning 14 times
than have a life.
Forward.
Forward, forward.
Mindset, all of that leads to one thing.
If you do not become a practitioner
of how to communicate on the
social networks of today,
you are 100% irrelevant.
Don't like it?
Tough.
Figure it out.
Execute it.
My friends, negativity
can lead at half time.
Kindness always wins the game.
Your life is predicated
on when you get real quiet
and you can't hear another
person's two cents.
The reason I can work 17 hours a day
is 'cause I'm not spending 15 hours a day
dwelling or looking back.
Faking it till you make
it is the great flaw
of this generation.
Please don't do it.
Please stop listening
to anybody but yourself.
Please eliminate negativity from your life
because if you want to really win,
it is absolutely by
reinforcing positivity.
So get real quiet in here.
Get real selective about who
you're spending time with,
and most of all, speak the truth.
Do the right thing.
Kindness is cool.
Truth is cool.
Don't act like you've made it.
Talk about the journey
of trying to make it.
Hey guys.
Thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all,
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.